hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to 60 seconds now I
realized what I was doing wrong in the
other episode and it's it's not entirely
obvious what I was doing wrong it is
simply a matter of fact that I didn't
give up my freakin things that I needed
to give up and I know I didn't but it
was not my fault because it's stupid and
I needed to give up my gun and I'm
actually talking kind of in this
bhrastika way because I need to get all
the things I need to rub it up a rub it
over rub it over a Romanova wife get in
my pocket please the daughter
Weiss's daughter got to be so big maybe
I could just forget about the daughter
for now Oh why's that take up two spots
oh dammit dammit dammit dammit I needed
more water and needed more water I don't
have the map
oh crap where's the map Brad oh crap oh
crap oh crap oh come on did I get the
map do I get it I don't remember I don't
know remember anything I got my mind
totally blanks out there what did I get
Bay 1 crap okay I got the map I got the
Scout manual I get the briefcase ago
okay we're good okay we're good we're
good okay this is actually okay all of
us made it in we got one extra can of
soup we got another extra can of soup we
got plenty of canned soup because
apparently I didn't grab ATS okay
we're gonna make it this time we're
gonna go on a buttload of expeditions
we're all gonna cure people when they
need to be cured we're gonna make sure
that people don't go insane this is
gonna be the one I can definitely feel
it I can feel it in my bones feel it in
my [ __ ] they gave us an axe nice ok good
good good good good
no expedition just yet oh we could go on
an expedition because we got no it's too
dangerous to go on an expedition we're
not gonna make them go on an expedition
we're not gonna do that until after the
radiation clears up because got enough
food to be able to last as well why is
the gun an option that was like the fun
screen like let's do something fun and
the gun was an option that has some very
serious implications that I don't know
okay so I'm gonna prep for a trip and
then everyone's gonna get fed tomorrow
and then someone's gonna go outside
because I think the radiation has died
down but just in case great news -
fallout outside is mostly gone it should
be much safer to travel on the surface
now that's good everyone gets supplies
and then Dolores who is a champion is
gonna go out there and is going to be
just fine she's gonna go with a gas mask
because I believe I'm not a hundred
percent sure on this one but I believe
the gas mask will help her fight off any
diseases I don't even know how we get
diseases down here unless we're all
breathing in fumes from the bucket and
taking bucket baths which is gonna be
bad sprockie busy was something to keep
us ossified for it gets worthless we did
the photo we were okay apparently
apparently we were looking for a photo
of a relative and we kept it in the
pages of the boy scout I'm assuming that
keeps us from going insane and that's
good
if we care about the future or kids we
need to start homeschooling Timmy or
maybe she'll for schooling is a right
choice of words we need to provide him
with some reading material as soon as
possible
Boy Scout Handbook sounds good as long
as it's done sir rip pays out making
paper our plan but we're gonna be good
we're gonna be good you might learn a
thing or two perfect
brilliant oh no oh no oh no don't shoot
the doggy Doo what can I do nothing I'm
gonna shoot doggy
I wanted you to doggie maybe I don't
need to do nothing but it could be a
hungry dog a quick shot was more than
enough to scare it away or maybe bring
down whatever dark creatures stalked us
in the darkness we never saw it again
Oh stumbled upon the ruins of a familiar
building your local bank
it looks like the bank was robbed just
before the blast of all was cracked open
with saws hidden in teddy bears but four
cans of food one can water and we lost
the gas masks that's okay everyone gets
fed today and we're still on schedule we
do Oh phone call Timmy go get the phone
please don't go crazy and don't get sick
please do not go crazy do not get sick
you okay good good okay we need someone
to go outside for supplies
we don't have a gas mask for him but we
can Mary Jane's toughest brick Mary Jane
is tough as bricks so Mary Jane's gonna
take the axe and nothing ain't nothin
gonna mess with Mary Jane Mary Jane is a
trouper she is a trouper and she will
get us what we need all right I believe
in her
yes okay perfect government wants
coordinates I'll give them coordinate
they need coordinates
I got him coordinates we need water
though I really hope Mary Jane comes
back with water we need water like bad
okay
strange noises in our pipes hat check
hellish yells outside Oh Dolores hasn't
spoken for a while that's it it's really
strange talking to her it'd be a good
idea yeah talk to your wife man why
wouldn't you talk to your wife why
wouldn't you talk to your wife
talking to Dolores helped resolve some
of her issues and doubts she feels
better now okay good and everyone gets
read and watered someone's out the door
bit scared maybe it's a friendly face of
an American shoulder should we open it I
don't see why not
what are they gonna do take our water
away from us ha ha ha oh good she's not
sick hey we got some poison control open
the hatch nobody there damn pranksters
making jokes even after the bucks we got
their acts back we got two soups we got
two waters we got one poison Mary Jane
you're champion yeah yes
okay so Mary James is gonna get fed
right now and then I'm just gonna pick
it all back up on 25 that's what I
should have been doing alone okay so
we're okay for now wait how many how
many we have three bottles of water
that's enough to last 15 more days
I don't want to say what we could send
Timmy how we could send Tamia I think
it'd be fine
if we did that ooh today we were visited
by strange-looking man who introduced
himself as a traitor he insists his
price okay so gas masks for ammo we
don't have either of those checkerboard
for a flashlight but we need a
flashlight get a bottle of water out of
this I'm down for a bottle of water
because frankly I don't know what the
suitcase is gonna do for me I really
don't know I really have no idea all
right I'm gonna I'm gonna let you go
with the bug spray damn it because
that's worked in the past where it just
so happens to come across a giant
horrible horrible assembly of bugs you
go Timmy you got it
Timmy's the man Timmy's probably not the
man Maryjane's the man some friendly
soul on the radio was talking about a
supply patch he lost two waters one food
we won't need to send anyone else if
Timmy doesn't even come back it's
actually fine oh this might be the one
unless some horrible thing happens which
it always does all right which side act
out scenes from our favorite movies okay
good good good there's no one go crazy
no one go crazy
Timmy come back come back to us Timmy
Timmy come back
Timmy come back please we love you it is
really lonely here okay Brady of ours
have been sound for the past few hours
we need our news we need our music we
all agreed we need to meddle with it
until it works don't meddle please no
one go crazy that would have been bad if
you did in a nude you went to be mad if
you would've did it okay everything's
fine
no one's gonna go crazy everyone is
a-okay we're a regular family so
arguments never got intense the fight we
just go on in - no one wants to speak to
each other let's hope this won't last
too long no don't do that don't do that
this Timmy yes everyone's so not crazy
oh and Timmy brought back a lot of stuff
you brought back the stuff the poison
you got a can of soup canteen
respectable tomato soup okay and two
cans of water and then two more cans of
soup we are fine we are a hundred
percent fine
Timmy you eat up because then we'll just
all eat on the 30th and everything will
be fine
no down our door today was a real
surprise it was not signed and said
whoever wrote it observing us from the
right kind of people they sent us to
send a single unarmed representative to
meeting today to find out more so we
send someone
Mary Jane looks in good shape but I
don't want to really want to lose her
okay okay all right
we're okay all right the meeting was
organized by twinsen okay that was it
twins that was the twins only okay
everything's fine we're all gonna eat
tomorrow we're not going on any more
expeditions where's the ball when you
need one really bored and need something
to occupy ourselves too many hours
accounting pipe droplets cards good
enough good enough cards are good okay
everyone's gonna eat everyone's gonna
eat cuz frankly we did we did good we
deserve this and we don't need to go out
yet until things get a little more
desperate we're fine
everything's fine I'm like oh god
everyone does not look fine everyone
looks horrible we're trying our best to
remain calm the situation we're in is
far from normal we might never get used
to it we hope to help to come soon Mary
Jane's pretty fatigued why is Mary Jane
deep why is Mary Jane fatigued well what
happened to Mary Jane what happened to
Mary Jane may be willing to offer a lot
for decent ammunition all I got is a
checkerboard but I have cards so I can
sacrifice the checkerboards because I
have cards depending on what he gives us
huh we offer checkers instead of
ammunition try to explain what
ammunition is $10 should nothing very
left check what he didn't give us
anything what was the point of that what
do you know that's how that was gonna go
son of a [ __ ]
son of an ass open in the name of
freedom Camus shout from outside our
door we weren't sure who claimed to be
representing freedom but we could hear
his group of people probably armed
anybody who introduces themself like
that is probably planning to kill
someone in the name of freedom should we
open it
I'm gonna look this one up okay so
apparently you may be visited by a band
of armed dark faced teenagers who are
fighting in the name of freedom and ask
if you're with the reds communists and
reveal themselves to be called
Wolverines this is a reference to the
movie Red Dawn when a band of high
school students armed and call
themselves Wolverines after their high
school mascot when a communist invasion
occurs in America so that sounds like
they're fighting against the communists
which mean that better not of going bad
for me everyone still alive
good what did they do we regret it
opening the door the minute we saw sandy
who was on the other side dark faces
rifles and determined looks abandoned
teenager we're doomed we thought then
out of the blue one of them asked us if
we're at the Reds we never supported the
Red Sox we confident confidently said
that we weren't the tension dropped
immediately those nice young people gave
us to Baz water they told us to have no
fear since the Wolverines are around
yes yes Timmy is not doing great it
would be good to talk to him and cheer
him up
yeah why wouldn't you do that why
wouldn't you talk to your own child
maybe if he was crazy that wouldn't be a
good thing to do even a word or two
maybe enough to brighten someone's mood
Timmy seems better by now okay this is
good this is really good we can survive
yes
and we don't have either of those we can
save it the right thing without losing
what we don't meet blues there's going
well is going unbelievably well the
military is communicating through the
radio we're sure it's signal to evacuate
out of here but turns out they need to
our help
speaker requested that all able citizens
should chop down a tree or two in the
nearby park it sounds ridiculous but
they're claiming this will make it
easier for them to extract us we never
even liked that part so let's do this
already yes we have an axe we can help
them we can help them help us help help
us help help us alfalfa alfalfa who
named alfalfa we chopped down as many
trees as we could it wasn't much but
hopefully he'll make a difference they
wanted the next time they get in touch
it better be from a tank marking our
lawn
okay so
we're good we're good for one more day
oh no I'm not gonna risk this a random
chance where we could get or lose two
cans I can't afford to lose two cans and
I got plenty of cans as it is we're fine
we don't need anything else we're
literally fine
everyone gets fed today we got enough
for 25 more days that would literally be
the most we've ever played this game we
can go insane in our brains it's going
to be very good oh my god we don't get
this time I will never survive oh man
seriously if we don't make it through
this time we are in such a good place
right now
if we don't make it through this time I
don't know what we're gonna do we're
gonna lose our goddamn minds see after
Delores returned from that last
expedition she was complaining of a
minor foot injury might have been a
right foot or maybe her left one of them
anyway it seemed irrelevant at the time
but now we're both her feet are swollen
we need to do something about it I'm
hesitant to use my med kit on you you
girl I guess we got to do it I don't
want to lose I don't I don't anyone to
go wrong but if someone gets sick then
we're gonna be in a lot of trouble but I
mean she doesn't get this then she's
probably gonna die all right we gotta do
something we might not have had to do
something but I have a funny feeling we
had to do something about that I'm
trying to keep my family as together as
possible here so that we can survive and
Mary Jane is my best soldier out on the
field
we're not going out when I go now we're
not going out
there's too many bandits it's too many
bandits later in the game we're not
going out I'm not gonna send people out
we're gonna be fine we can survive this
we can survive this together as a family
bandits are out the door promising us
the worst fate we can imagine if we
don't let them in it's time to make a
stand or surrender I'm going to use the
lock cuz I can give up my gun and
hopefully that will trigger them to
rescue us soon right yes good okay good
good good good good good good we were
able to fight off the bandage this time
there's no guarantee that won't come
back we need to be prepared at all costs
we didn't think the small padlock would
be enough but it discourage them it's
good Mayor James is feeling safe
everyone is just fine we're not going
out one of the cupboards in the shovel
was a bit shaky so we pulled it down to
give it a new home in the process we
discovered a secret door
where's lead no idea but let's find out
okay why the Frick knock up you what's
the first thing to do when you open the
door leading to a place you don't know
open fire Bam Bam our bullets struck the
wall and guess what we hit a water pipe
we were able to fill a few water balls
with all the water that trickled from
the bullet holes okay great okay first
aid kit is of no use and we need to do
something about it for some bizarre
reason we believe we can use lethal bug
spray to produce some additional
medicine maybe it'll work we won't know
until we've tried it what else am I
gonna do with the bug spray oh my god it
worked
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] deadly bug
spray can result in just enough drugs to
replenish an empty spots kit what do we
do we just open the flagon to sprayed it
in there willy-nilly and that worked oh
my god that's amazing is incredible is
astonishing
okay when we were to knock at the door
we decided to open a heart rate goes up
a bit fortunately this time it wasn't
blood thirsty Raiders but the brother
and sister we pretended they're
ambitious trying to construct a few
houses can elfia don't have an axe
hopefully that's not gonna screw me over
later we are not alone there's a huge
hairy bunny beast that seems to be
hiding in one of the pipes we can't let
it be in here when we sleep shoot the
sucker bang bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang a bang bang a bang bang bang -
you did a cans are saved - bad for the
hairy mutant and we kept are done enough
I'm shocked about that
see Mary Jane looking fine everyone's
fine god they better rescue us soon a
gang of thugs are banging on the door
asking us to surrender how do we respond
with a gun to the face take our gun come
back damn it are gone broke after that
wasn't the only gun that we needed
trusty rifle but maybe I could repair
with the book that was kind of thing
that happened before maybe it's gonna
happen again
wait judging by the sound of gunfire and
screams it seems like a band of thugs
has taken control the area going out
could be very risky yeah we're not gonna
do that we got we're fine we got another
15 days ahead of us
we only steered away from casinos
gambling dens and the like so when a man
came to our door and told us he used to
be a gambler - water-bottle bet we don't
need it we don't need the water we got
more than enough water water is not our
problem I wouldn't even risk it if the
food bet was there we're not gonna do
that
oh no group of bandits on the other side
demanded we walk out with our hands up
oh god damn it
ah ah
we hope nothing bad will happen to him
grab Ted and took him away oh god damn
it gang of firefighters dressed like it
surrender all of our supplies drive us
out with fire if we don't comply what is
this [ __ ] if I didn't trade the bug
spray for medicine this game is
impossible this is impossible
I did everything right I did everything
right I did have why didn't I get
rescued why why didn't I get rescued why
I had everything it was like an
unstoppable chain of madness stopping us
from succeeding is this game actually
possible is this game actually possible
is it possible is there a pizza on the
goddamn roof right that a reference to
Breaking Bad
it's impossible it's possible I know I
know it's possible I know it's possible
I know it's possible but god damn it
have you ever seen such a string of bad
luck befall a player of this game up
until this point right here that is
absurd I had everything in the palm of
my hand everything was going swimmingly
for me if it was beautiful and then I
lost it all was it because I wasn't
going on in ethics but I was playing it
safe there were bandits everywhere
everywhere there were bandits it's not
like I want to get in the supplies I
needed what am I gonna have to blow up
oh well I think that's enough 60 seconds
for me I don't know what I'm gonna come
back to this maybe I'll livestream it
until I beat it that'll be a more
interesting way to get to the end of the
game than what we've done thus far but
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what ways I went wrong in
the comments and as always I will see
you in the next video